parle-moi de l'avion le vol océanique 4
2 0 allant de hissero à JFK
[Musique]
on sait combien il y a de pirates de
l'air 5 ils ont des exigences
particulières non mais on a reçu des
signaux intermittents de notre agent
infiltré à bord
un agent sous couverture il a intégré la
cellule extrémiste transnationale
tu vas bien
allez si on lui donne du temps ce n'est
pas le début d'une histoire héroïque
on voit le trop trop vite
dans 10 minutes nos oiseaux seront en
position pour mettre fin à tout ça ce
qu'on est en train de faire aujourd'hui
le début de leur fin
c'est une ogive nucléaire
confirmé
vous avez le contrôle de l'avion on n'a
pas assez de carburant vous pouvez
vraiment piloter il reste 97 minutes de
carburant
[Musique]